gentlemen i let me i i have the intro
for this right gentlemen
what if i told you you could get anime
for free
for free gentlemen are we [ __ ]
jumping right into it because
that's going to be the first topic for
today but right now i have with me the
boys god and joey and i am monkey
you didn't even say hello you just you
just like [ __ ] opened up with this
that's like
everything sales people like illuminati
conspiracy theory
every good sales pitch starts with the
hook literally reminded me of that wolf
of wall street
sell me this man because you know now
they're listening they're intrigued
how can we get free animation what a
hook they don't want to know about trash
taste they want to know why
did you just use like the og open there
did you just oh my god i can't [ __ ]
talk today
i said free anime i wasn't stumbling
tell me more salesman who's totally not
shady
well if you just go to the kickstarter
page
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about anime is that what
it's called
anime what's the first topic today uh
two weeks ago we wanted to talk about
this last week but chris came on
inconvenience stars again we would have
spoken about this last week because we
wanted to talk about anime tube
we know chris goes into fits when we
talk about it so we're gonna be like
three weeks late but the whole debacle
is kind of finished now yeah talking
about that we have all the information
like it like lived and died within the
span of a day
i think yes pretty much it was very
interesting essentially what happened is
uh this thing called anime tube popped
up on kickstarter
and yeah offered to give all the kind uh
anyone really yeah free free anime free
anime
and you're probably thinking well i
think you know they probably only got
like you know c rate shows yeah
yeah yeah yeah really terrible what do
they have they they said they were gonna
they were in talks to get
evangelion love hina which has been
stuck in copyright ally but knock up
right now
licensing specifically love hina i don't
know i don't know
who like just specifically picks lafina
attack on format alchemists even though
these were already all on streaming
platforms already yeah yeah you know and
i imagine that
the ones that aren't have been out of
print for the past twenty they say
zero as well i didn't i didn't see the
list they've got
everything it's animate shoes you know i
mean you know and so i i can't
i don't know how much these properties
are worth but i can't i can't imagine
you getting evangelion for less than
like a hundred million or something
ridiculous you know
that sounds absurd but it's probably
worth that much right so clearly these
guys are big bucks to spend around i
mean i'm just glad
a company is giving the power back to
the people and taking on small indie
companies like
so [ __ ] license holders yeah so taking
on small indie companies like sony
and att you know like you know someone's
gonna take these were they going to do
what were they going to do with it so
yeah so essentially this kickstarter
promised that and it and it raised in
like one day
like a hundred and ten thousand dollars
yeah it literally came out nowhere
because i remember we were we literally
came in the trash taste studio in the
morning
and then it was just all over my twitter
timeline i was like what the hell was
going on
and we all looked at it and we were just
like wait this kickstarter launched
yesterday and it's raised
over a hundred thousand dollars
promising people free anime
legally and i'm just like what is going
on right now
it was an absolute disaster april was
about three months ago guys like
you're a bit late to the joke right now
yeah it was just uh
a mess it was hilarious a mess
the the you know i think it it's so many
levels to it and there's so many things
that are really sad about it one
um you know i think it's safe to say
that this was uh
either the most over ambitious
kickstarter of all time
yeah uh or it was uh they were lying
all the most genius scam now yeah i mean
you know you have to be careful when you
say these guys because you can get uh
sued so trying to get trash take suit
here jerry okay but from what i i saw
yeah it's
a scam
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah well i mean i'm protecting myself
i'm i'm not going to say the s word
but uh i'm going to say that it looked
very sus
i'll say the other
it's a sassy bucket is what it is you
know i genuinely wonder because
you know again they promised to have all
these titles that
there's absolutely you know not even
netflix or amazon can get all of these
shows right
this is some serious amount of cash and
negotiating power
that i doubt a kickstarter would be able
to convince the japanese investors
flicks and like
sony can't even get the rights to some
of these yeah what
what suggests to anyone that this
kickstarter group will be able to like
evangelion literally couldn't be
even gun's been out of print for the
past 20 years you couldn't get the
license rift until netflix somehow
probably don't even want to know how
much netflix oh no the creator didn't
even have the rights to it for the
longest time until i have to [ __ ]
fight with guy next to get about
it's insanity yeah i mean the thing is i
think
there's as you said there's so many
layers to it because you know in theory
it's a nice idea you know
having somewhere where you can watch
anime legally
truly utopian world
what part of he feels bad because we're
like we're like laughing at they're like
imagine trying to take on the big guy ha
ha funny yeah but
but like if it was a good attempt i
would be yeah right right
if it was a good attempt but like keep
in mind you're taking on like
companies like sony like netflix you
know like like
people who you know have have a bit of a
dollar in their pocket you know
and like yeah i i don't think we're
trying to be like yeah we love
corporations and stuff like that because
i i feel like a lot of this was driven
by
you know the people's hatred towards
corporations and you know i get it you
know if
you don't want to support the big
corporations because of whatever reason
you know
i get it but there's there's a
difference between not wanting to
support like
big corporations and then like
supporting
like whatever this is yeah right it's
blindly accepting anything it's like not
what it's like
not wanting to buy paracetamol for your
pharmacy so you go to like the local
drug dealer you know like like
what's the yeah yeah i guess
it's like it's like betting in a horse
race but the horse's two legs
that's why i felt so kind of just sad
about it really i felt sad that there
was
enough weebs out there that were this
desperate to like stick it to the campus
yeah they would throw their money into a
voice dude weebs want free [ __ ] man
at the end of the day this is also what
i don't understand is that we have weebs
that are this dedicated to say [ __ ] you
to companies
that are willing to give money away but
you could they could just pirate it if
they really want to
really get it for free i'm not saying
you should i i condone that
do not do it but i mean it's also like
you're kind of
basically i mean it's also like with the
money that they
gave to this kickstarter right because
like there were a lot of people who are
giving like
hundreds of dollars to this kickstarter
and like some some people i saw were
giving literally thousands of people
yeah i mean there was
when i looked there was a thousand
backers giving a hundred thousand so
it's
a rough on average a hundred dollars
each giving a lot of money that's like
you know a year's subscription yeah to
netflix
it's not about the money it's what the
message i'm sending it's about sending a
message the message of
i got scammed yeah well i mean i mean
it's it's the it's the thing is
where if anyone just like literally used
a single brain cell
like you think about like the logistics
of this
like just the logistics of why this
would not work in the first place
or like you know a hundred thousand
seems like a lot of money
sort of just like any normal person it's
like a drop in the [ __ ] bucket
for like animated licensing fees and all
that stuff
you can maybe license half an episode no
no not even that
you can maybe license the thumbnail of
an image half an episode of like a
c-tier anime
yeah pretty much yeah yeah i mean yeah
like we and
what surprised me is that they were the
shows that they were listing as the
shows they were going for
what like the [ __ ] triple a titles
that
are worth millions and millions of
dollars right i mean god knows how much
netflix actually pay to get evangelion
out of licensing hell because evangelion
was out of like life
couldn't be licensed by any western
company for like feels
like a decade literally since it was
made yeah yeah like since like
since adv like collapsed i can't think
of any other
like company that has successfully
licensed evangelion
and i think people like to think of
anime still this kind of underground
thing but some of these shows are easily
you know worth over hundreds of millions
of dollars like these titles right like
i think the merchandising of these shows
as well right think about like the vip
is so exciting i think about the mega
shows like
any of the shonen jump shows like my
heroes how much is the attack on
titanfall
[ __ ] demon slave yeah demons right i
mean
a billion dollar property yeah yeah
exactly he's already proven to be that
yeah so i
it's really i just i don't understand
like every none of this i who were these
thousands of people who gave money like
i legitimately wanted that
yeah i legitimately want to know it's
it's obviously very young impressionable
anime fans right who are just
hoping for this yeah society right i
wonder if some parts of it we're just
completely like
oblivious about like we take for granted
some of them because we yeah i mean we
work with japanese companies we know how
these things are
you can't go around saying you're in
talks that is that is like the biggest
no-no in business
like and especially here i feel like
it's never a done deal until it's done
dealing
did you read the faq what was that that
what do they say
oh okay i read some of it what was the
do you remember the thing about
licensing or something
i remember like one of the faqs uh one
of the questions was
uh isn't anime licensing really
expensive yes
they legit went um actually um
anime licensing isn't as expensive as
everyone makes it out to be
the only reason nobody does it and
nobody talks about it is because of ndas
but
we are in talks with real japanese anime
licenses
and uh that was pretty much that was
pretty much the answer to the question
can they get anime licenses they
literally just shot themselves in the
foot because
they didn't have to answer that question
you can't say you're talking to these
companies
also it's all very secretive you know
yeah intentionally so
yeah all these companies are like yeah
do you know this guy
yeah well yeah because it was a guy
there was a so they also
uh i think the person uh i'm not sure
the ceo someone representing right stuff
anime yeah yeah which is the american
company i think which uh buys the
licenses for
again i'm not sure either way they they
buy licenses or they sell or they sell
dvds they reached out being like uh so
apparently you've listed some of our
titles
uh and you said that we're in talks and
the guy tweeted him saying that we've
never been in talks
and then they replied saying we sent you
a message on linkedin
that was there we're in talks i'm in
[ __ ] talks with all the people that
email me about weird [ __ ] then oh no
what the [ __ ]
it's just like bro bro i dm'd you why
didn't you dm back i sent you my
linkedin dm please respond
we're in talks now right hundreds of
millions of dollars are at stake because
of my linkedin dns i sent you a dm
please give me
um the anime license please give me the
ips that's that's that's how anime
licenses
i'm in talk with all my favorite
succubuses from all the hindi yeah i've
sent them a message they haven't
responded yet but we're in talks
we're we're working on an arrangement
it's just insanity
we're part of this one-sided
conversation it was just it was just
i mean it's all it all burned down in
flames luckily but yeah it was just oh
my god it was such a
fun it's just so bizarre to see and you
know we knew it was going to like
come down in flames yeah i mean i think
right now it's like been taken off
kickstarter right as far as oh yeah okay
it's still there but the funding is
stopped
oh okay so so now i'm going to give them
any more
that's good okay that's good okay okay
so yeah it is
so kickstarter suspended 111 000.
yeah i like i don't know how true this
is but i did see a screenshot on my
prop up my timeline the other day though
that uh
shows that they haven't given up they've
started like a newsletter
which you can which you can subscribe to
for a dollar
so for a dollar for this newsletter you
can subscribe for updates
updates of what talks in the end oh no
i legit don't know and it's like it it
is like on this week's newsletter we're
in talks with adv
trying to get the right it's just it's
just absolutely tragic like
it's obvious that you know i'm not being
funny but there's a reason why like
netflix doesn't have its own discord
server as well and they had their own
discord server and they started banning
people
and it's like what is this this is
[ __ ] yandere devs game what is this
this is like
what's going on here it's so obvious
that they're just because they've done
this like two times before
yeah as well and they've failed twice i
saw they've
made other kids so they're trying to
make this kickstarter this is their
third attempt
it and i think another app similar to it
popped up
on the microsoft store and was taken
down before as well so yeah
they have a history of doing this and
failing and whatever but clearly
you know every time it comes around it
seems to get some money so i
i guess why not i guess i got some real
balls to do it like three or four times
no shame man i'm sorry if you [ __ ]
gave money to that kickstarter like